what is the meaning of this whole thing
what's the meaning of life why
this uh
time is fundamental it's marching
forward
and along this
long timeline come along a bunch of
descendants of apes
that uh have come up with cellular
automata and computers and now computers
why
i have so many different answers to this
question it depends on on what day i
would say that given the way of the
conversation we had today i'd say the
meaning
well we make our own meaning i think
that's fine but i think the universe
wants to
explore every possible configuration
that this allows us to explore and this
goes back to the kind of question that
when you're asking about yasha and the
existence and non-existence of things
right so if the universe is a turing
machine it's churning through a load of
states
you think about combinatorial theory
before assembly theory so everything is
possible
what yasha and i were saying is um
well not everything is pop
we don't see the commentary explosion we
see something else
and what we see is um
evidence of memory
so there's there clearly seems to be
some interference between
the commentary explosion of things and
what the universe allows
and it's like this kind of constructive
destructive interference
so maybe the universe is not just about
um
it is assembling objects in space and
time
and those objects are able to search
more
space and time and the universe is just
infinitely creative and i guess
i'm searching for why the universe is
infinitely creative or is it infinitely
creative and maybe the meaning is just
simply to make as many objects create as
many things as possible and i and i see
a future of the universe that doesn't
result in the heap there for the
universe the universe is going to
extract every ounce of creativity it can
out of it because that's what we see a
nerf right and if you think that
almost like intelligence does not
conserve that maybe creativity isn't
either maybe like
it's an infinite well so like creativity
is ultimately tied to novelty
you're coming up with cool new
configurations of things and maybe that
just can continue indefinitely
and uh this human species that was
created along the way is probably just
one method like that's able to ask
the universe about itself it's just one
way to explore creativity maybe there's
other meta levels on top of that
like obviously as a collective
intelligence will create organisms maybe
there'll be
organisms that
uh
ask themselves questions about
themselves
in uh in a deeper bigger picture way
that we humans do first to ask questions
about the humans and then construct some
kind of
hybrid systems that ask themselves about
the collective aspect just like some
weird stacking that we can't even
imagine yet and that's stacking i mean i
have discussed this stacking a lot with
um with sarah walker who's a professor
of physics and and astrobiology at asu
and we argue about you know how creative
the universe is going to be and is it as
deterministic as all that because i
think she thinks she's more of a free
will thinker and i'm of a less free will
thinker but i think we're beginning to
converge and understanding that
because there's simply a missing
understanding right now we don't we
don't understand how the universe we
don't know what rules the universe has
to allow the universe to contemplate
itself so asking the meaning of it
before we know even know what those
rules are is premature but my guess is
that it's not meaningless and it isn't
just about that and there's there are
three levels of meanings obviously the
universe wants us to do stuff we're
interacting with each other so we create
meaning in our own society and our own
interactions for human humanity but i do
think there is something else going on
but because reality is so weird
we're just scratching at that and i
think that we have to make the
experiments better and we have to
perhaps
join across not just for the
computational lists and what i tried to
do with yahshua is meet him halfway say
what happens if i become a
computationalist what do i gain a lot it
turns out because i can make turing
machines in the universe because on the
one hand i'm making computers which are
state machines inspired by turing on the
other hand i'm saying they can't exist
well clearly that's that i can't have my
cake and eat it so there's something
that weird going on there so then did
the universe have to make a continuous
to a discrete transition or is the
universe just discrete it's probably
just discrete so if it's just discrete
then there are
i will then give yasha his
turing-like property in the universe but
maybe there's something else below it
which is the constructor that constructs
a turing machine that then constructs
you know it's a bit like the
you you generate an a computing system
that then is able to build an
abstraction that then recognizes
it can make a generalizable abstraction
because human beings with mathematics
have been are going to be able to go on
and build physical computers if that
makes any sense
and i think that's the meaning i think
that's you know as far as we can the
meaning will be further elucidated with
further experiments
[Laughter]
uh
well you mentioned sarah i think uh you
and uh sarah walker are just these uh
fascinating human beings
i'm really fortunate
to um have the opportunity to be in your
presence to study your work to follow
along with your work i'm big i'm a big
fan
like i told you offline i hope we get a
chance to talk again with perhaps just
the two of us but also sarah that's a
fascinating dynamic uh
uh for people who haven't heard i
suppose on clubhouses where i heard you
guys talk but you have a incredible
dynamic and i also can't uh wait to hear
you and yosha talk so i think if there's
some point in this uh
predetermined or yet to be determined
future
uh
where the the three of us
you and sarah or the four of us with
yosha could meet and talk would be a
beautiful future and i look i look i
look forward to most features but i look
forward to that one in particular lee
thank you so much for spending your
valuable time with me today thanks lex
it's been a pleasure
you